this sanitation company
disposes of its waste by dumping it into
the amazon river
and unfortunately they're not the only
ones
all over the world people are treating
bodies of water like
they're giant garbage dumps and
experts say that continuing these
practices will result in catastrophic
damage to marine life
but what if we're just not dumping our
trash
in water that's deep enough what if
we dumped our trash down in the deepest
part of the ocean
with the immense pressure down there act
as a natural trash compactor
how would all that garbage affect the
rest of the ocean
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we sunk our trash into the mariana
trench
the mariana trench is a vast crack in
the earth
deep in the bottom of the pacific ocean
its deepest point
is 11 kilometers below sea level the
trench
is so big that we could theoretically
keep stuffing our trash away there
for thousands of years but only three
people
have ever made it down to the bottom of
the trench
so how likely is it that we could get
all the world's trash down there
before we dive too deeply into that
let's find out how much trash we're
talking about
we produce over 2 billion tons of waste
every year and this is expected to
increase to almost three and a half
billion tons
by the year 2050. to put it in
perspective
that would be 1 000 times the volume
of the great pyramid of giza
to get rid of the waste we've tried
things like throwing it into landfills
and
burning it up but neither of these are
working out too well
both landfills and garbage incinerators
release toxins that
leach into our soil air and groundwater
becoming long-term hazards to our
environment
and to our safety so it's time to get
creative
and try something new and that brings us
to the mariana trench
the trench is so vast that it could hold
as much as
970 000 billion
tons of waste that's enough to allow us
to keep stuffing away the world's trash
for
thousands of years the pressure in the
trench is also very high
it's comparable to the pressure that a
tower of 2
000 elephants would exert on a surface
smaller than one square meter
we could use that pressure to our
advantage as it will compress
any waste we put down there it would be
like
when a car crusher compresses a car
this would allow us to put even more
trash into the trench
now all we have to do is figure out a
way to get our waste down there
one option would be to transport the
waste down there using
a submarine but that would be very
expensive
for comparison the submarine used to
bring filmmaker james cameron to the
bottom of the trench
cost 10 million dollars and only one
person could fit in that sub
a better solution would be to use a pipe
system
similar to the waste pipes that some
construction scaffolds use
the garbage pipes would have to
withstand the high pressure of the ocean
floor
and their paths would have to be
carefully planned to account for
different depths along the trench but
even if we could get all our trash down
there
would it be a good solution for our
waste problem
it doesn't matter what part of the ocean
we dump our trash
into it's still going to cause pollution
waste is filled with dangerous metals
chemicals and
micro plastics that can leak out into
its surroundings
these chemicals and microplastics could
be passed on to
us humans through the fish we the water
we drink and
even the air we breathe so
rather than finding new places to dump
our garbage
maybe we could focus on trying to
produce less of it
instead the zero waste movement is
already picking up speed can you imagine
how quickly our planet would recover if
we produce
no waste at all well
that's a story for another what if